and four of the last five since that
knee pop in the game with Miami
involving Derrick Jonah
[Applause]
before five so let's take them all in
most knitting we've seen it a lot
scooter mark Dirk de risco face on the
offensive end of the floor it is still
got shoot every time from the down
screen knocking down his first shot
games 23 wins 17 losses for the mammals
[Applause]
his last shot against a rookie
virgin
17 pounds of dirt it will be the first
month attack don't you see that
so a couple of threes made by dirt this
is nothing like watching greatness and
Dirk Nowitzki pulls the trigger on yet
another three-pointer the championship
team a great teammates of dirt as he
shoots a corner to call that before we
introduce you Brian Cardinal a long
career but but also said hey this is
this is the time the time
that's Wedgwood a while
for you to make a shot off the glass I
think we just saw the old statue shot
there they'll break this man's great
career you did not come here to spend
the whole section when you're up that
big break won't rebound a pow
Dirk a lot of times that's an excellent
time by power after it hits miss grant
out the rebound play at the AT&T Center
in San Antonio oh yes
oh yeah that's nice
dirty hanging on the rim
that's a 50 right there all the judges
holding up tens right run into Princeton
out here you get dumps out of it
two more he's got 26 they get into more
your chant going
why not
[Applause]
he finds miniskirt on the cart
exam Brunson traces it down there's dirt
[Applause]
basketball dirt looking for the numbers
tonight here at the end for Dallas and a
chance for dirt here
mouse in the house closes